[Musique]
depuis que l'humain séjourne dans
l'espace les experts tentent de contrer
les effets négatifs de ses voyages sur
le corps des astronautes ils peuvent
désormais compter sur l'aide d'un allié
assez improbable un écureuil
les robots s'y sont rendus mais jamais
des humains pour quiconque voudrait
fouler mars les défis physiologiques
sont considérables les astronautes ont
beau s'entraîner dans l'espace pour
contrer les effets de l'absence de
gravité ils reviennent souvent avec les
muscles atrophiés
et de récentes études nous indique que
la solution à ce problème pourrait bien
venir des écureuils
l'écureuil terrestre à 13 lignes qu'on
retrouve majoritairement au centre des
États-Unis et du Canada hiberne dans sa
tanière pendant 6 mois sans manger
son corps se refroidit atteignant la
basse température de 5 degrés Celsius
son rythme cardiaque ralentit sa
respiration aussi
inactive pendant une longue période on
pourrait croire que ces tissus et ses
muscles subissent d'importants dommages
il n'en est rien
un chercheur de l'Université de Montréal
s'est penché sur la question alors qu'il
étudiait à l'université du Wisconsin aux
États-Unis
pense avoir trouvé l'explication au sein
même du système digestif de l'écureuil
oui explorer nous avons examiné une
hypothèse qui existait dans la
littérature scientifique depuis près de
30 ans
elle avançait que les animaux en
hibernation
recyclent l'azote présent dans l'urée
qu'il fabrique à l'aide de leur microbe
intestinaux
et qu'il réincorpore cet azote dans leur
tissu pour leur permettre de construire
de nouvelles protéines pendant la saison
d'hibernation c'est azote que l'on
trouve dans l'URI de l'animal est
essentiel à la formation des protéines
dans les tissus comme les muscles entre
autres lorsque l'écureuil à 13 lignes
est en éveil l'été l'urée se retrouve
dans les reins puis est éliminé dans
l'urine
mais lorsqu'ils hiberne l'urée se dirige
plutôt vers les intestins où loge des
bactéries bien spéciales celles-ci
réussit sa séparer l'azote des autres
éléments de l'urée l'azote est ensuite
réintégrée dans l'organisme permettant
de régénérer les tissus sans ces
bactéries l'écureuil ressortirait plus
affligée son hibernation un groupe en
particulier retient l'attention
est le groupe de bactéries qui étaient
le plus apte à produire l’enzie muréate
un enzyme nécessaire à la séparation de
l'azote urique est-ce que nous avons
remarqué d'intéressant c'est que c'est
l'un des seuls groupes qui augmentent au
cours de la saison d'hibernation
puisqu'il réussit à se nourrir de l'urée
le groupe de bactéries anistibles survit
donc à divers et permet à l'écureuil de
se réveiller vigoureux prêt pour une
saison d'accouplement et si les
astronautes aussi pouvaient utiliser ce
procédé pour revenir sur Terre en
meilleure forme
certaines études réalisées dans les
années 90
suggère que les humains sont capables de
recycler l'azote du Reiki de la même
manière que les animaux qui hibernent
mais dans une moindre mesure
lorsqu'il est adité ou sous-alimenté ou
lorsqu'il est dans l'espace l'humain
subit des pertes musculaires
l'écureuil s'expose au même pression
lorsqu'il reste inactif dans son terrier
mais lui n'en souffre pas pour que les
humains puissent en profiter aussi il
faudrait comprendre comment se processus
de récupération de l'azote hors de
l'urée s'améliore au fil de l'hiver chez
l'animal
[Musique]
voilà
qui est le plus intéressant dans l'étude
c'est le fait que le processus de
récupération d'azote urique s'amplifie
lors de l'hibernation contrairement aux
autres processus du fonctionnement de
l'écureuil
si nous pouvions comprendre quel
mécanisme le permettent
cela pourrait nous fournir des
informations pertinentes pour améliorer
la vitesse de notre propre système
la machinerie nécessaire pour que ce
processus se produise chez l'humain a
peut-être juste besoin d'être amélioré
pour lui permettre de régénérer ses
muscles lorsqu'ils sont sous pression
je pense que la forme la plus simple
serait une pilule pro ou prébiotique qui
en se montrer le microbio intestinal
humain
si cette technologie est appliquée aux
humains ce serait selon moi d'abord
utile aux humains sur Terre avant de
l'être pour ceux dans l'espace
les résultats de ces recherches ont à ce
point frappé d'imaginaire que des
écureuils ont récemment été recrutés par
l'Agence spatiale canadienne
mettre la main sur la façon d'optimiser
ce processus chez l'humain pourrait bien
être un petit pas pour les astronautes
mais un bon géant pour l'humanité
[Musique]